>> SEAN: FOCUSING IN ON THE
FLORIDA CRUCIAL ELECTION WE HAVE
SENATOR-ELECT RICK SCOTT WITH
US.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAD A GOOD COURT
RULING.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHERE WE ARE
AND WITH WE GO FROM HERE.
>> SO AS YOU KNOW, I ENDED THE
NIGHT TUESDAY NIGHT WITH A
57,000 VOTE LEAD AND NOW I'M
DOWN TO 15,000 VOTE LEAD.
WE WANT TO GO TO COURT TO GET
THE SUPERVISOR OF ELECTIONS IN
PALM BEACH AND BROWARD COUNTY TO
ACTUALLY DO THEIR JOB, TO NOT
VIOLATE THE LAW AND TO PROVIDE
US INFORMATION.
WE WON THAT LAWSUIT TODAY.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
GETTING THAT INFORMATION.
WE'RE, YOU KNOW, WE'VE HIRED THE
RIGHT LAWYERS.
WE HAVE GIBSON DUNN, WHO WON --
ARGUED THE CASE WITH BUSH VERSUS
GORE SUCCESSFULLY.
THEIR LAWYERS, BILL NELSON'S
LAWYERS WHO IS TRYING TO STEAL
THIS ELECTION, THEY WENT TO
FEDERAL GOT TODAY TRYING TO GET
THE CERTIFICATION POSTPONED.
THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO DO THAT,
SO BASICALLY TOMORROW, MY WIN
WILL BE CERTIFIED BY THE COURT
SUBJECT TO A RECOUNT.
THEN THE 40 SOMETHING THOUSAND
VOTES NEEDED TO DO A RECOUNT.
AND THEN WE'LL JUST KEEP GOING.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY ARE GOING TO
DO EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO STEAL
THIS ELECTION.
I'M SO DISAPPOINTED IN BILL
NELSON.
A CAREER POLITICIAN HAS BEEN
THERE FOREVER AND ALL HE'S DOING
NOW IS HE'S HIRED HILLARY
CLINTON'S LAWYER TO SAY, AND HIS
LAWYER SAID IT, I'M HERE TO WIN
THIS ELECTION, NOT A FAIR
ELECTION, NOT MAKE SURE ALL THE
BALLOTS ARE CAST.
I'M HERE TO WIN THIS ELECTION.
>> SEAN: LAWS BROKEN HERE.
WITHIN 30 MINUTES OF THE POLLS
CLOSING, BY STATE LAW, YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO LITERALLY HAVE A
VOTE TALLY IN TERMS OF MAIL
ABSENTEE BALLOTS, THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE COUNTED WITHIN 30
MINUTES.
WE'RE ALSO SUPPOSED TO HAVE
OBSERVERS, AND BY LAW, EVERY 45
MINUTES, THERE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
AN UPDATE.
NONE OF THAT HAS HAPPENED HERE,
AND THIS PARTICULAR WOMAN THAT
WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT, BRENDA
SNIPES, SHE HAS A HISTORY OF
VIOLATING FLORIDA AND FEDERAL
LAW.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE 72 HOURS
LATER, PLUS, THAT WE'RE IN A
POSITION, WHERE THEY ARE STILL
DUMPING BALLOTS.
THEY NEVER REPORT ON TIME.
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWING THE PEOPLE
TO OBSERVE AS IS PROTOCOL.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
>> WE'VE GONE TO COURT.
WE'VE ASKED THE FLORIDA
DEPARTMENT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
INVESTIGATE.
BUT THEY HAVE COME UP, IN
BROWARD, BROWARD BY ITSELF,
ELECTION NIGHT THEY CAME UP WITH
78,000 MORE VOTES.
WE STILL DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION ON IT.
THAT'S WHY WE'VE GONE TO COURT.
ANOTHER 15,000 IN PALM BEACH
COUNTY.
NO IDEA, HOW THEY SHOWED UP,
WHEN THEY VOTED OR ANYTHING
ABOUT THEM.
WE WON THE LAWSUIT TODAY.
WE'RE WAITING TO GET THAT
INFORMATION.
SO IT'S JUST -- IT'S HARD TO
BELIEVE.
YOU CAN ONLY ASSUME THAT THIS IS
JUST, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE TO
ASSUME THAT THEY ARE DOING THIS
JUST FOR FRAUD, TO TRY TO STEAL
THE ELECTION.
>> SEAN: BUT THERE ARE 67
COUNTIES, GOVERNOR,
SENATOR-ELECT, IN FLORIDA, HOW
COME THE OTHER 65 COUNTIES NEVER
HAVE ANY PROBLEMS AND THE
PROBLEMS ALL EXIST IN THESE TWO
COUNTIES?
AND AT WHAT POINT, WHERE IS LAW
ENFORCEMENT, FACT THAT THEY
WOULD ALLOW THREE FULL DAYS TO
HAVE ZERO SUPERVISION.
THEY SHOULD HAVE GONE IN THERE
AND SHUT THIS PLACE DOWN BECAUSE
AGAIN, THEY ARE JUST VIOLATING
LAWS LEFT AND RIGHT, WHICH SHE'S
BEEN FOUND TO DO.
SO IT SEEMS NOW, GOD ONLY KNOWS
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE IN THE 72
HOURS, AND, BY THE WAY, SHE
EXPRESS -- SHE DIDN'T APPEAR TO
LIKE YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEMS LIKE SHE HAS A STRONG
OPINION AGAINST YOU.
>> RIGHT.
WELL, CLEARLY, SHE'S GOT, YOU
KNOW, SHE'S GOT A BIAS, AND --
MY EXPECTATION IS LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILL FIND OUT
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
THE COURTS, WE'RE WINNING IN THE
COURTS SO THAT WILL HELP US TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
LOOK.
I WON, OR THE CITIZENS OF THIS
STATE WON THIS ELECTION FAIR AND
SQUARE.
I AM THE NEXT -- I'M THE
SENATOR-ELECT IN THE STATE.
WE'LL BE CERTIFIED TOMORROW AND
WE'LL FIGHT EVERY ONE OF THESE
LAWSUITS AND WE'RE GOING TO WIN.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET THESE
LIBERAL ACTIVISTS FROM ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY COME DOWN HERE AND
SAY WE'RE GOING TO STEAL THIS
ELECTION FROM SOMEBODY THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS
STATE.
WE'RE GOING TO WORK HARD EVERY
DAY AND WIN THIS.
>> SEAN: SO THERE WILL BE AN
INVESTIGATION.
THIS WILL GO ON BUT YOU'RE
SAYING BY SATURDAY YOU WILL BE
DECLARED THE WINNER?
>> THE FIRST THING WILL BE THE
CERTIFICATION BASED ON
INFORMATION THAT COMES FROM THE
LOCAL SUPERVISOR OF ELECTIONS.
WE SHOULD BE CERTIFIED AS THE
WINNER AT THAT POINT ON SATURDAY
SUBJECT TO A RECOUNT, AND THEN
WE'LL HAVE THE MACHINE RECOUNT
THROUGH NEXT THURSDAY.
IN THE MEANTIME, ANY -- VOTES
THAT COME IN FROM THE MILITARY,
WHICH CAN COME IN A LITTLE BIT
LATER, THOSE WILL BE COUNTED,
AND THEN IF I'M BELOW ABOUT
21,000, THEN THERE WILL BE A
MANUAL RECOUNT AFTER THAT BUT IN
THE MEANTIME, YOU KNOW, THE
DEMOCRATS, BILL NELSON, WHO
CAN'T STAND TO LOSE IS JUST
GOING TO FILE EVERY LAWSUIT THEY
CAN AND WE'LL HAVE TO FIGHT BACK
EVERY LAWSUIT THERE IS.
>> SEAN: UNBELIEVABLE.
GOVERNOR, NO ONE SHO
GOVERNOR, NO ONE --O
GOVERNOR, NO ONE -- SHOULD HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THIS.
THE HISTORY OF THESE TWO
COUNTIES, EVEN THE PANHANDLE, 27
DAYS EARLIER, HIT WITH ONE OF
THE MOST SEVERE HURRICANES WITH
SO MUCH DAMAGE, THEY DIDN'T HAVE
A PROBLEM.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE, AND IT
LOOKS LIKE A BANANA REPUBLIC.
WE SEND OBSERVERS OVER TO OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WE NEED AN OBSERVER IN BROWARD
COUNTY.
MAYBE WE CAN GET SOMEBODY TO
OBSERVE FROM NOW ON, AND SHE
CANNOT BE ALLOWED TO DO THIS